こんにちははじめしゃちょーでその動画を見ている方に学生の皆さんはいらっしゃい
ますでしょうか
皆さん米しゅんおうか知っていますで僕がまずブレザーの制服を着れるかと言いますと
とある
検証のためにブレザーを着ておりますみなさん学校に通学するときどうやって通学して
いましたでしょうか人によっては床でつく近くの学校に行っている人も
いる車でパパやママに送り迎えしてもらった人も居ると思います電車通学の人もいる
自転車通学の人も居ると思います中には遠くて新幹線で通学してるみたいな人も居ると
思いますそんな通学で私学生時代に一つ
夢があったんですその夢とは何か
そう
ヘリコプター
投薬
やってみたいんですよねはい学生の頃には絶対できませんでした
想像ヘリコプターでな塩するかとかもよくわかんないんですけども例えば高校生の時に
ヘリコプターで通学したら絶対めちゃくちゃモテるしかっこいいと思ってたんですよ
どんな夢を今回叶えてみたいと思います
そして今回ですねそんなヘリコプターをなんとソフトバンクさんが準備
て頂きましたありがとうございます
本当にソフトバンクさんがいないと続けしなかった危険だと思うので本当にありがとう
ございますただ条件があるんです
青春たるものを制限されたら清酒できない説あると思いますいっていうで私今から一時
的に学生に戻るんですけども1か月使える技が2が3 gb だった場合1日に使える
容量はたったの100名が
バイトその一で自分の気がしか使えないというルールで私は学生に戻らせてヘル2通用
でしたいと思います
3 gb もあれば多分学生乗り切れると思うよ多分それも含めて検証していきたいと
思いますそれでもか静岡に住んで東京の高校に通う学生という設定で青春を送らせて
いただきます果たしてヘリコプター通学は
早いのかどうか検証していきましょう com 4
俺の名前は枝葉塩受賞高校2年生だ俺はとある事情により
静岡から東京の学校に通っている
もちろん新幹線通学なのだが遅刻して新幹線に乗り遅れるとまず学校にまにあわないん
だこれはそんな遅刻した時の朝の話
やべス勝ってる場合じゃないまずい
この時間だと新幹線だと学校にまにあわない俺の家から学校までの通学時間平均タイム
5時間28分43秒
もうマニュアル方法はないのかいやー
はんっそうだヘリコプターを使えばいいんだ
よくわかんないけどヘリコプターって何か早そうだしこれなら間に合うかもしれない
急いで近くの日が終わるだろ急いで近くのヘリポートに行こう
いけない近く地下フェイ
無事でしたお願いします入りポッドまでない
どれくらいかかりそうですかねー
20分
の道です
暇ながら質な方では触るか
[音楽]
虹コプターそこでリフター持続
やってるから250キロぐらいてるらしいです最高速度が300km
これが高まにゃうかこれ
[音楽]
ええええええ
スマホを触っているうちに付いたようだこれが減り com これがヘリポート彼は
すごいすごいすごい
よしスマホ触ってさっという間に減ることですだぞ
まだ間に合う
[音楽]
おおおおおおおおおおお
お願いします東京の学校までお願いします
[音楽]
こなんというわけで早速せちょっと上から東京て学校へ向かっております
新幹線のタイプ5月は28分43秒を超えることはできるのでしょうか
暗いシーズンに空の旅を楽しみます
同じ席だってください本当のプレゼントに食べたわー
俺はセロリしてパンこれぞ実はほんとリガズィ具合これがしどうかを待つれたよ
うううう大江を休めた静岡世界っていう
[音楽]
すごい凝った高いところが見たことないな増税性に関連で静岡から
ビリーで等定期とめちゃくちゃおもろい先生40分ぐらいで東京に帰る
はいいいやーただ僕の僕的理由すごいいいことなんですねー
檻さあアートも披露とロボする含めはあそこがポイントで
なぜございましたん
胡桃なる日だ動いこんな綺麗な2 way デザインで
[音楽]
forever ネットワークん
ha
nare
んでしょうか富士山の便座で辛くなってきました豪亜佑美
桜きれいに写る鏡鍋整数最高
何まあくださいするなぁ
おおよそ1000メートルくらいたいんだどうでしょうかうーん
泥上空へ
まあまあレンジ役目と直で出会い000
ま w だ後いく間
多い
sa 場で温泉の帝王と入学るんですよ
入っています
います
ます
[音楽]
学校のみんな
の前でて美玲
投稿するのが俺の夢だ下がっ日
皆様になりますでしょうか東京ガスよくできましたん
俺たらもうには倒せない白黒のフォトン
se ドーム ebay
nobara た墓はん
者様にまあん
というわけでもう統計でもとって来ませんだして俺は奴人
マニュアルとカーン
いつになく
ているございまーす
ぬーん
味はまずしてるでしょ
やべぇよ5このまま遅刻しちゃう
なにこの問う
ヘリコプター
あーこれを
ていました
ていた
me
橋岡したぞ
あいつ縁が来やがったよ
日高縁で北村第1キーたったなよ
言われていました
[拍手]
dj
みんなもねー
かかったタイムが1時間28分愛知工科だよ
[音楽]
漆黒したよもう
はあああっもう一で自分の気がつか祝っちゃってんじゃん
全然たんないよもう
先週終わったぁー
f ザクソフトバンクの大容量のスマホだよねっ
いいの大容量
[笑い]
ブーバーみんなつい4キャラクターの動画ティ
運動グッズがただしないですねそれうまい
入っていうわけで実際に静岡から東京まで縁で数学してみたんですけども
タイムは一緒でしたあのほぼ一緒だったんですけども減りすごい景色が良くて楽しかっ
たですでも新幹線でいいなと思いました
はいというわけでですねソフトバンクだったら5歳から22歳の方なら誰でも
ソフトバンク学割適用で最大1年間機が使
高台になりますさらにウルトラ機がモンスター plus に加入された方は通話基本
料月980円が半年間なんと0円でお使いいただけますというで学生の皆さん
スマホめちゃくちゃを使うと思うんですけども大量の木がないと生主やってられないと
思うんで
この機会にぜひ利用してみてくださいじゃあ
me
ni
あっはっ